I guess when it comes to the actual  writing of the piece where it really  really becomes what it's going to become  is it's about character from the  dialogue just comes out of the character  and I don't leave the characters I let  the characters lead me uh both as far as  who they are and the conversations and  even the scenario itself I mean like for  instance if I've got a character here  with this glass and I have every  intention of getting him to where that  glass is yeah well that's a good idea my  part I think but once I get them going  there they might not they might reject  the glass right and they go somewhere  else and they are the ones that know  best